The Joe Rogan experience.
Well,
I think people can develop these patterns
of behavior that are destructive with
anything, whether it's with alcohol
or cannabis or you know, yes,
sex or anything people get,
they get in ruts, know.
It doesn't mean that the cannabis is bad
as means that you are on a bad mental
path. Yes, exactly. I mean,
I'm not encouraging it for everybody
because some people are genuinely
biologically it doesn't jive
with them. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The fundamental thing is we as adult
human beings need to take responsibility
for our own lives and our own decisions
and we need not have that responsibility
over to governmental institutions,
especially when it concerns something
as intimate and personal as our
consciousness. And, uh,
my view is the ancient world had the
right attitude to this kind of thing and
the modern world does not.
And that we can sit down and learn
a lot from the ancient world.
A lot of people ask me, you know, Hancock,
you've been arguing that there's a loss.
There's been a lost civilization in the,
in the, in the human story. But what,
what sort of civilization do you think it
was? Well, one of the things I think is,
was a civilization that use psychedelics.
I think it was a civilization that
emerged from shamanism but did not stay at
the hunter gatherer a stage.
But that took the essence of shamanism
and integrated it into a very different
kind of civilization from our own,
which pursued things in different ways.
A lot of archeologists have said to me,
but we don't find any plastic
bottles from the ice age.
That means there was no
advanced civilization during
the Ice Age. Well, hang on,
maybe an advanced civilization might
have decided never to get involved in
plastic in the first place.
Maybe they would have been a
clear choice not to make plastic.
Maybe they did things in
completely different ways.
Maybe they cultivated powers
of the human mind that,
uh, we dismiss and regardless,
completely, completely unimportant,
you know, woo woo. Yeah. This is the
thoughts about Egypt, correct. It's about,
about Egypt and about other things.
I mean,
the specific example I give is above the
king's chamber in the Great Pyramid are
five further chambers.
And these chambers are rushed and flawed
with granite beams that weigh about 70
tons each and there are hundreds of
them and these 70 ton granite beams,
which to put in context,
a 70 ton beam is equivalent in weight
to 35 large SUV is these 70 ton granite
beams have been elevated to a height of
more than 350 feet above the ground and
carefully and precisely,
uh, placed in position.
It is very hard for archeologists to
explain how that was done using purely
leverage and mechanical
advantage. You can say, oh,
and perhaps they built a ramp and,
and, and hold the stones up the ramp.
But then you have to confront
basic laws of physics.
You can't hold us at stone weighing
tens of tons up a slope that exceeds 10
degrees.
Then you start doing the calculation.
How long the ramp do I need with a 10
degree slope to get to 350 feet above the
ground? And the answer is
you need a fucking long ramp,
which should still be there because not
that it couldn't have been a sand ramp,
I would've collapsed under
the weight of those stones.
It had to be as massive
as the pyramid itself.
So this begins to seem like
an absurd idea. The, the,
the idea that is foisted
on us by archeology,
maybe the idea that they regard as absurd,
namely that psychic powers were
cultivated by ancient civilizations,
that they could use powers of the human
mind that we have allowed to lapse.
Maybe that idea deserves
further consideration. Um,
we have gone down a path of
leverage and mechanical advantage.
We used to relying on machines,
but we hear anecdotal reports of people
who have telekinetic powers who can move
things with their minds of people
who have telepathic powers on.
Our automatic reaction is to just dismiss
all of that because science says it's
impossible. Um, B, B, B,
because a science regardless,
consciousnesses as local to the brain
and doesn't see how it can exert itself
outside of that.
But maybe we should open up to those
possibilities that we're dealing with a
very different kind of culture that
used techniques that we have allowed to
lapse and maybe we could wake
those techniques up again.
Maybe the ability of human beings to
do almost superhuman things is resident
within all of us,
but sleeping well.
It's pure speculation that they use
some sort of a telekinetic power,
but it's pure speculation,
but it's absolute that they did
something that we don't understand.
If you think about the distance
between us and the construction,
just the modern accepted
construction data, the great pyramid,
it's more than 5,000 years ago or
close to 5,000 years ago to a parent is
supposed to be about 4,500 years
old. Yeah, it's really old.
It's incredible to think that someone
back then could do something that would
perplex us today with modern
machinery and that somehow or another,
they figured this out.
It's almost like what they had done
was leave behind something that was so
stripped tenders,
so monstrously impressive that it would
transcend time and that you would have
to look at it even thousands and thousands
of years later and say, hey, like this,
this defies conventional explanation.
This is not as simple.
And I've seen some of the conventional
explanations of the construction,
the pyramid,
and they conveniently neglect
those chambers above the
king's chamber. They do.
They conveniently neglect a lot
of those massive stones. Yeah.
And it's because it's, it's one of
those things you just go, oh, I dunno,
what does this Jamie, they're the,
they're the chamber above the,
above the above the king's chambers.
And each one of those floors is,
consists of a row of 70 ton granite
blocks that had been raised 350 feet above
the ground. And not only that, but
brought from us one in the south of Egypt,
500 kilometers south of the
south of the Great Pyramid.
So if there's any time in history where
you could go in a time machine and go
back and observe,
would that be the time?
I am just completely fascinated
by the ice age at the moment.
Have you had one shot to go back and
see what it was like in some place where
you wouldn't go to the construction?
The Great Pyramids,
I think right now where I'd go is
12,800 years ago in the beginning of the
younger dryas just to see,
because I think that's where
the whole human story changes.
I think that's where we change tracks
from one path to another path and
following those cataclysmic events of
the younger dryas between twelve thousand
eight hundred and eleven thousand six
hundred years ago, following those,
the signs of civilization that we see
emerging are not the beginnings of
civilization there.
A restarting of civilization that
had existed before the cataclysm.
And for that reason, um, I would, uh,
I would like to be present
during that cataclysmic event,
if only to satisfy myself that it was
indeed a comet. You see, the, the,
the one thing,
there's no dispute about any more is that
the younger dryas was a cataclysm that
you can't, they can't argue
about that. The, the, the,
the megafauna that, uh, that,
that die off, the disruption of human
activity that takes place at that time,
the huge climate changes.
This was a cataclysm by any standards
where the argument still goes on is what
caused that, what caused the
cataclysm. I vote strongly for comet,
multiple fragments of a comet hitting
the North American ice cap and hitting
Greenland as well.
But there are other researchers in the
field like my colleague Robert Schoch who
thinks that the sudden is more
involved. This is healthy. This is very,
very healthy that they should,
we should be approaching this problem
from many different perspectives and
trying to figure out what the fuck cause
this extraordinary event that occurs at
a pivotal moment in the human story,
the end of the Stone Age,
the beginning of the Misa
Lithic the end of the ice age,
the beginning of the
current age of the earth.
And suddenly we see these
signs of civilization
appearing and in places like go
back to the tippy.
Those signs already include
highly sophisticated knowledge
and that's why I feel
we really need to investigate the Amazon.
There are,
there are three places in the world
which are really lacking in the
investigation right now.
One of them is the Amazon five and
a half million square kilometers,
very little archaeology done. Another
is the Sahara desert, the Sahara desert,
tough place to work. I can understand why
there's little archaeology done there,
but the Sahara desert was green during
the ice age has had a completely
different climate regime.
We should consider the possibility that
missing parts of the human story are
there. And then under the continental
shelves, because sea level rose 400 feet,
these are three domains that archeology
has largely not investigated and,
and it is largely not done.
So they say,
well why would we spend the
money on marine archeology?
It's much better to spend it on looking
for shipwrecks rather than looking for
signs of a lost civilization
because we archeologists, no,
there was no loss of realization.
So that's the argument
for the resources there.
And, and the same, the same with
the Amazon. And the same with the,
with with the Sahara desert places in
the very places in the world that those
amongst us who are charged
with the responsibility of
interpreting the past have
not looked at are the very
prices we should be looking at.